vous connaissez mon ayoub oui bien sûr
elles un beau bateau à la très très
bonne et les flotteurs
elle
on a chanté avec vous
mais on n'a pas répété mais quand elle
veut mais c'est des chansons de noël
comme assia mononcle écouter enrico
macias quand j'étais tout petit sans
arrêt qui avait une chanson au liban qui
se répétaient que les français ne
connaissent pas c'était quoi et l'on
m'appelle l'oriental s'y connaissent pas
les français parce que j'ai demandé à
tout le monde se connaissait cette
science et nous ça fait comment enrico
et l'on m'appelle lorientais
sentiment
car moi je suis sentiments et pourtant
je
on a surnommé marais
il faut saluer aussi la raison
alors vous devez aller chanter à
constantine vous deviez aller chanter où
vous devez aller chanter je vais chanter
voilà en chine le 18 mars et puis
partout en algérie alors à constantine
annaba par bonne pleine scène ouais tizi
ouzou et alger dont constantine ses
droits à polluer oran et alger celle 27
donc si une tournée en algérie et après
on peut dire qu après 38 ans donc il ya
38 ans vous avez quitté l'algérie s'est
jamais retourné et la boucler et en
quelque sorte bouclé c'est un quelque
chose que je n'aurais même pas imaginer
en rêve et puis qui viendrait pas de
m'arriver commun
comme quelque chose c'est même pas
historique c'est messianique ouais c'est
mentionné c'est assez beau une vie
normale
non a dit lui sa valeur non non pas du
tout ça m'impressionne pas du tout je
crois que les jantes une fausse opinion
de la réalité des choses je pense que
tous les gens qui naissent de rang
devrait leur mettre un gilet pare-balles
aussi parce que à chaque fois qu on est
on est condamné à mort toute façon ça
bien m'ont tellement à l'automne
quel déconneur
alors vous y allez en plus pendant la
période de l'aïd donc la fête du mouton
qui la fête du pardon dans la dans la
région musulmane et vous partez avec 200
autres juifs d'algérie qui étaient
là-bas à l'époque et qui je pars avec
200 enfants d'algérie de notre
confession et nous allons
reconstruire un pont entre l'algérie à
la france un pont qui a été un petit peu
coupé pendant longtemps pendant 40 ans
et puis voilà je suis fier d'être le
leader de cette merveilleuse histoire
cette nouvelle page de l'histoire que
j'ai chanté depuis 40 ans alors à la fin
de la semaine la presse
disait quand même que les conservateurs
les islamistes en parlant de vous en
algérie disait vous étiez l'envoyé du
gouvernement d'israël et que les 200
invités que vous emmenez avec vous était
destiné à officialiser le retour de la
communauté juive dans le pays que
c'était inacceptable
alors d'abord
je suis content de vous mais ai posé la
question pour mettre au point beaucoup
de choses
premièrement
ces gens là qui essayent de
perturber mon voyage en algérie ne
réussiront pas le faire parce que je
suis absolument déterminé parce que ce
sont des gens qui ne représente rien du
tout je sais pas que je les méprise ou
que je les négligent au contraire
ils ne sont pas représentatifs pour se
permettre de m'interdire d'aller en
algérie et c'est pas le moment et la
vendange est interdite est maintenant au
bout de quarante ans il ya le peuple
algérien n'en soit avec une écrasante
majorité qui désirent mon retour en
algérie ou même titre qu'un enfant
d'algérie et le président bouteflika est
le seul habilité
musicalité alors vous permettez oui je
suis content qu'il y ait des opposants à
ma venue quelques opposants vous savez
comme ayant la et en a quatre qui
peuvent déteindre sur pas mal mais moi
je sais que il ya 99% d'algériens dont
le président bouteflika qui désirent ma
venue en algérie ce qui prouve que
l'algérie est sur le chemin de la
démocratie ça simplement c'est quand le
fln de constantine qui
qui s'est manifesté mais moi je me suis
jamais mêlé de la politique intérieure
de l'algérie la seule chose c'est que
j'ai toujours regretté qu'il y ait de la
violence en algérie je les jeux les
dénoncer
comme j'ai dénoncé celle qui a existé
pendant la guerre d'indépendance et que
je respecte les morts de tous les deux
tout deux des deux côtés mais ça tout le
monde a eu les mêmes souffrances enrico
je peut vous [ __ ] le bourdon enfin
cette personne ne me [ __ ] al bourdon
ouais et je le dis sans aucune polémique
je le dis sans aucune peur et je le dis
je rassure tout le monde tout les gens
mon public
mes proches ma famille qui a peur pour
moi moi j'ai peur pour eux mais moi j'ai
pas peur pour moi et je les rassure tout
de suite parce que je sais que l'action
qui est menée c'est une action positive
et dont le but est la finalité c'est la
paix et la fraternité
et c'est d'une page tournée pour nos
enfants et nos petits enfants
si on continue à
ce je veux dire cautionner ce genre de
choses ça veut dire qu'on a on amènera
rien au futur et on aime ça n'a rien
d'un enfant né sur les enfants écoutent
et au risque de ma vie je suis prêt à
aller jusqu'au bout je me fous
éperdument de ma vie j'en ai rien à
[ __ ] par rapport aux symboles que je
représente et si je devais faire marche
arrière je pourrais plus me regarder
dans une glace jamais
[Applaudissements]
alors donc votre histoire comment cela
commence à constantine où vous allez
retournez donc au mois de mars rue
biscarra première guitare à l'âge de 12
ans et votre père joue avec raymond
leyris j'ai créé mon tonton raymond
qu'on voulait comme vous l'appelez et
vous sortez ce disque en hommage tu peut
zoomer mon garçon voilà vous sortez ce
disque en hommage à raymond leyris
c'est de la musique arabo andalouse
malouf comme on dit un peu c'est pour ça
que je n'ai pas semblé parce que c'est
de la musique on n'écoute pas comme ça
en 30 secondes ça s'écoute quoi s'est
inscrit à ce titre de la musique
classique mais c'est de la musique c'est
un mélange de musique classique de
musique folklorique oui j'suis musique
qui est né à grenade et à séville
lorsque les communes les communautés
juive et musulmane doit exister ensemble
en espagne et puis qui ont été obligés
d'être chassé par isabelle la catholique
en 492 et u11 du sud en
1990 qu'un jeudi
vous savez je sais beaucoup de choses en
un coup beaucoup de chance en or mais je
pourrais tu l oriental bafiba fille de
mon pays qu'est ce que tu fais dans une
logique de pardon je peux te dire un mot
on a eu une rencontre impromptue donc tu
te souviens peut-être mais tu sais
peut-être pas que c'était moi un jour
tel qu'un petit pépin avec une 305
blanche tente une go noir
mais j'ai eu un peu peur oui c'est vrai
j'ai eu un accident malgré moi avec
magnum avec ma fille et mes
petits-enfants là et c'était
ponemon en a 350 et oui et tu été barrée
j'étais un sale auch le dit alors si
c'est toi vraiment tu es le roi des
[ __ ] tiens pourquoi parce que tu as
failli tuer des petits enfants dans la
voiture je suis je un gt gt je sortait
de boîte
gt5 c'est vraiment toi
tatiana charrier non mais écoutez je
vois temps plein par domjan pratique
maintenant tu es très chaude va mettre
un pain alors c'était pas moi alors
toi non non il est chaud c'était pas moi
mais ça j'ai pas d'humour maintenance
très court je propose que tu raconte
l'histoire de bon pied bon oeil pour
détendre tout le monde
on rappelle qu'une seule histoire les
général qui pète c'est l'histoire que tu
raconte comment tu connais que ça tu
sais je sais tout des toits rico
je te dédie au départ je sais tout de
trompe pas pourtant
ça c'est l'histoire je réponde à mes
petits-enfants
alors
il y a et tellement les quatre endroits
cette histoire le petit con 4 dans le
sens à ce qu'il a trois quatre mois mais
j'ai vachement bien ancien hier lent
mais ce qui m'a tuer c'est bon pied bon
oeil ce assez puis l'accident et tourne
enfin bon je m'excuse 1 tu m'as bien
chauffé
bien donc vous avez commencé votre
carrière à l'âge de 15 ans avec cheikh
raymond leyris ce qu'elle vous rendez
hommage dans mon jeu des gens auxquels
vous rendez hommage dans ce cd est bon
ben c'est vraiment c'est l'exemple même
de quelqu'un qui était
multiconfessionnelle puisque son père
était juif sa mère était chrétienne et
lui chanter en arabe donc on peut pas
être plus l'oecuménique que lui et vous
tombez amoureux de sa fille suzy qui
deviendra votre femme alors quand il a
rencontré sa femme en plus agricoles et
l ena tu le payes petits noeuds comme ça
au bout des nattes et tout le temps mais
je vous ai tout de suite hein mais
depuis tout petit ouais depuis la rue
biscarra déjà il était amoureux non
hélas la première fois qui quand il a vu
sa femme suzy pour la première fois il a
eu honte d'avoir des culottes courtes
c'est la première fois de sa vie où il a
eu en outre d'avoir des canaux de course
première femme s'appelait suzie l'un des
chiens s'appelait mannix c'est dans les
livres d'histoire
il était bon c'est bien assez bien la
comparaison à me plaît beaucoup non non
c'était pour citer des noms j'ai retenu
c'est pas une comparaison un peu surtout
parce que dans le privé on l'appelle
dallas non c'est vrai il connaît tout
mais battus et moi et mathieu non
j'étais petit je ne suis pas de
l'enquêté moi je voulais m'excuser après
l'accident et puis j'ai appris des
choses sur sa vie il dort à gauche de la
gauche
mais vraiment
mini cela pour moi j'ai un peu pain avec
de l'huile d'olive
continu continu rappelle moi des
souvenirs passent des points je suis le
droit de manger du pain avec des vidéos
ni de l'ennemi maintenant harry potter
sa foi qu'ils adorent cela woerth débout
simple du pain 2002 livre une corniche
bleus
est ce que tu sais qu'avant de quitter
l'algérie en 62 quand tout le monde est
parti un haricot était déjà venu en
france quelques temps à fontainebleau
exact et c'est la première fois où vous
avez rencontré le racisme en face hier
le racisme vous l'avais pas rencontrée à
constantine en algérie là vous habitiez
vous l'avez en rester là le racisme
c'est enfin il y avait un peu de racisme
quand même ça a existé mais il était
organisé on s'en apercevait pas tandis
que quand je suis arrivé à fontainebleau
là j'ai rencontré le racisme parce que
j'étais différent physiquement des
autres j'aime pas les 8 si vous lisez
les types oui il y en a un qui me disait
par exemple
d'ailleurs je vais casser la figure et
puis ça m'a coûté un renvoi il me dit
j'aime j'aime pas les juifs mais mais
les arabes je les aime bien parce qu'il
m'avait pris pour un arabe voilà il
m'avait tout de suite édifié sur l'oral
à vous les avez us et que donc il
voulait pas il va un club dans ce que
dans ce lycée a porté le nom il va un
club et enrico voulait rentrer dans le
club et puis les mecs bon il le stopper
un peu et un jour il y avait une fête du
club et le décor s'est effondré et
pendant qu'ils remontaient le décor
enrico il a joué avec sa guitare et les
mecs ont trouvé ça génial et c'est comme
ça que je suis devenu chanteur et c'est
quand ils ont cassé le décor que j'ai
meublé il à le blesser son premier
récital à préville murs du lycée pour
aller en des prêts l'identique cabaret
très bon imitateur enrico ah oui son
point fort c'est jusqu'à ces noms c'est
vrai mais à brûle pourpoint comme ça
j'ai pas tellement c'est pas content
pour chanter un vrai chien et à mohsen
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
est alors donc quand vous avez votre bac
pour tourner en algérie donc vous
retrouver suzy et vous devenez
surveillants dans une école et ils
apprenaient aux petits arabes il leur
apprenait nos ancêtres les gauloises en
fait c'est assez surréaliste dois dire
comme j'étais instituteur pas sûrs vers
way à l'instituteur au pardon populace
hélas à l'époque à celle à
la valise ou le cercueil quoi
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais
quand je repense à ces moments là c'est
à la suite de l'assassinât de ton
vraiment que toute la communauté juive
et la communauté française a décidé de
partir c'est vraiment sûrs en tentant
vraiment on a demandé en fait deux de
partir incroyable 38 ans après des
tournées oui et justement il ya des gens
qui m'ont dit mais tu vas tu vas chanter
cette chanson dans l'ain tu vas pas
changer les paroles ouais jamais de la
vie elle a chanté telle qu'elle est et
c'est ça que je voulais dire je voulais
dire que quand je vais la chanteur
l'algérie c'est une chanson j'ai jamais
pu enlever de mon répertoire jamais en
plus en lever de mon coeur est jamais pu
enlever de ma mémoire
et même quand je vais retourner en
algérie je la chanterais encore parce
qu'il ya quand même quelque chose qui
est partie de nous mais qu'elle a
retrouvé pour nos enfants et nos petits
avait raconté l'histoire sinon adjoint
christophe deux minutes chic et la hesse
qui peut rentrer mellinet ce qu'on peut
faire rentrer et christophe dominici
maintenant bonsoir venir
bon vous restez on va arriver avoue
christophe vous m'en voulez pas je
termine avec mon client précédent et mon
crayon
c'est le confessionnal
donc j'ai terminé l'histoire donc vous
arrivez à argenteuil vous chantez dans
un cabaret à pigalle et le dernier jour
c'est pour ça que je tiens à aller au
bout de cette histoire le dernier jour
enrico a fini dans le cabaret à pigalle
a fini sa séance en récital disons et il
ya un coup de téléphone et c'est igor
barrère qui à l'époque faisait cinq
colonnes à la une vous verrez ça dans
les émissions d'arthur
igor barrère qui faisait sa commune
qu'il appelle et qui vous demande de
venir jouer à dieu mon pays pour sa
colonne à la une vous y allez vous jouer
cette chanson vous l'a chanté entouré
par des parts des pieds-noirs bouleversé
et donc là c'est le succès et jallet
le loup à la fois paris tu m'as pris
dans tes bras vous savez de salon mais
bien pour 69 des 60 noeuds aujourd'hui
j'avais trois ans
voilà et là vous faites olympia et puis
depuis vous avez combien de fois
l'olympia soit 16 ou 17 16 ou 17 fois
voilà
la lettonie est comme vous êtes
justement quelqu'un de sincère je vais
vous faire l'interview mensonge on ne
bouge pas par le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les nuits là j'avais su servir signifie
toi tu la fais iref quel rigolo berry
elle peut pas s'empêcher cette voie là
alors moi je surveille ce côté là tout
est surveillé l'autre côté ça a bougé
non un max gallo et à un peu bouge ça
max gallo bon recommence on recommande
j'aime pas balancer mais je le soupçonne
d'avoir les ginks
patients
ni c'est compliqué bon
j'ai alors l'interview mensonge enrico
c'est très compliqué c'est à moi que sa
viande est ce que vous gagnez bien votre
vie
non j'ai un pauvre type mais donnez
donnez donnez donnez moi donnez donnez
donne
est-ce que vous avez déjà frauder le
fisc
et oui mais qui n'a pas fraudé le fisc
et qui claque à le dire dites la vérité
se mettre au chant se couvrir est ce que
vous êtes toujours catholiques
intégristes
toujours mais je suis un dévot mais
alors les fidèles tous les dimanches le
shabbat
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes quand même toujours un peu
extrême droite un peu antisémite quand
même enrico non halal à ne me parlait
pas de ces gens là avec leur nez crochu
et tout ça et tout le pognon qui gagne
est au voyage allait retourner dans
votre pays et surtout pas en israël
le pen il allume le poste il s'est pas
vu faire un vous vous trouvez comment
physiquement en ce moment un haricot
je suis très laid
c'est le mensonge mensonge mais voilà
vous trouvez très bien en ce moment et
grossit
non mais j'ai blanchi
tu parles de pas des régimes parce que
c'est son gros problème a fait sans
problème c'est la nuit dans le frigo le
parler qui venaient en huile d'olive
barisal harris est ce que vous
fréquentez toujours les bars par ron
hubbard américain
toujours je suis tous les soirs mois un
tous les soirs sur tous les soirs je
fréquente ces boîtes tous les soirs et
je veux fumer le cigare et c'est nancy
vous c'est ça je fume pas le cigare
vérité je fume des cigares à
cette furie pluie est ce que vous êtes
plutôt enrico plutôt haschich ou plutôt
en herbe
elle est dure celle là
disons haschich parce que chez nous on
dit
ça vient de ce mot la fin du mois ashish
ça veut dire que chercher ça veut dire
on aime bien avoir la tête un peu dans
les nuages un ca entre deux mondes
artificiel dont vous êtes plutôt en
herbe en fait dans l'interview l'ancien
je suis et rb je suis attaché
dernière question vous avez peur de
mourir
ah oui j'ai très peur de mourir très
très peu gilet pare-balles en algérie
pas gilet pare balles
merci bon il est arrivé quand même
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu